entrepreneurship for me was something
scary
it was something totally unknown i
thought okay you have to be steve jobs
to be an entrepreneur and i'm not steve
jobs
so that's not for me i can understand
business i can understand finance i know
spreadsheets really well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upwards labs and hillel at
stanford this one is all about
project management meet rena vernovskaya
the ceo of 280 group
the world's leading product management
training and consulting company
her team provides custom solutions to
help product management teams deliver
customer focused products that matter
prior to 280 group rina was an analyst
in mckinsey and co's investment office
and in the leadership program at metlife
she holds a ba in economics and european
studies from amherst college
and an mba from harvard business school
rina vernovskaya thank you for joining
me today how are you
i'm great thank you so much michael for
having me i'm excited
i'm honored to have you here we're gonna
have so much fun talking about product
management
talking about your experience with the
280 group and and how
you're helping teams of product
management work within
large enterprises the difference between
working with large enterprises and
startups
and but i have to go all the way back to
you playing pool
what was that about you know it's
actually people who really play pool so
this is exciting
uh so yeah i did it for about a year
uh i worked i played in the american
pool association
in a bar pool league in new york city
while i was working in finance and i
absolutely loved it i learned so much
about actually yeah about learning
i can i can go on for for hours about
the characters that i met
um but it was it was so much fun and i'm
very competitive as a person
so it was a great way for me to uh
release some steam as well
i love it so finance during the day then
paying playing pool
uh competitively at night that makes
perfect perfect sense to me
but rena your journey is so is so
incredible
from uh you know from mckinsey to
metlife at harvard business school
somewhere in the middle there yeah and
now uh you're also
at the ceo of dutch a prime did i say
that right that's your prime elf yeah
yeah i'll talk a little bit about that
so
um why why don't i start and uh kind of
let you know
uh i started my career in finance right
so i thought
yeah uh i started my career in finance i
was
uh i was you know i graduated high
school during the
start of the financial crisis and so i
thought wow that is a very interesting
problem
how did it happen that the you know that
this
went uh below the radar for so
long by so many smart people so i
thought hey that's an incredible uh
problem maybe i you know maybe some
smarter people can find out what is a
credit default swap and
and and that's what really interested me
in the finance industry
um and so i worked for mckenzie uh right
after college for a period of three
years
i and i worked in credits i was their
credit analyst
i had a blast um i had you know that was
my first time
my mentor there i still talked to him
today um
and i'll tell you throughout my story
like i think it's always about the
people it's about the people you
surround yourself with
yeah so what does a credit analyst do
what is it what is that
um so so you know most people when they
think about uh
when they think about the stock market
they're just thinking about equity but
there's a
there's other financial instruments um
with bonds
that uh that have different it's just a
different way of making money in the
financial market and credit default
swaps were the big
thing in uh 2008 which blew up because
they were essentially insurance products
on
on on bonds um and it was a way for you
to are
to to be highly leveraged and have a
high exposure
um to a bond so long as it didn't
default
you were you were fine but of course as
we know so many bonds defaulted
and so there were that was really what
caused the liquidity crisis
especially in greece uh so
so that's that's a long story i'll i'm
deviating but
the point is i i loved working in
finance i thought they were really
interesting problems but i realized that
when you work in finance you're
primarily solving problems on a screen
you're not really working as much with
people and i love people
uh and so that's what drew me to
consider business school and for anybody
listening business school it's so true
it changes your life
um when you can you can not only be
exposed to so many different people so
many different ideas
but you can try new things and that's
what i did i went into business school
thinking
oh maybe i'll actually start my own
finance firm because if i'm leading a
finance firm i can
you know there's there's little women
represented in finance
maybe i can even show and be an example
um and start an investment firm with
hiring women because uh women are
honestly
underrepresented and also really really
smart so
right um so i i went to business school
and then i decided okay i want to work
with people
so i went and i did a summer internship
with the metlife
um in their global leadership
development program that's among that
life
i need at least two or three sentences i
got two three sentences about harvard
business school it's it's you know it's
it's not at the ordinary business school
that you go to tell me a little bit
about
why is it so life-changing why what is
it about this two-year experience where
you're foregoing a full-time job right
you're effectively you know paying
somebody a full-time salary
to give you that education what end of
that experience what is it about that
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you why it
was life-changing for me and it's not
because i met my now husband there
um which also happens uh but uh
okay so i came into harvard business
school with this
idea like i just said about okay i'm
gonna stay in finance
um and then i got exposed to so many
different people so many new ideas as i
just mentioned
um and the other thing that it did for
me was
entrepreneurship for me was something
scary
it was something totally unknown i
thought okay you have to be steve jobs
to be an entrepreneur and i'm not steve
jobs
so that's not for me i can understand
business i can understand finance i know
spreadsheets really well
but i'm not an entrepreneur and at
business school was where
where i actually started realizing what
entrepreneurship
was i saw many different kinds of
examples
and i saw that it was attainable and
reachable for myself
um in new ways so the exposure to people
and ideas
in such a compressed time frame two
years is a long time but the
amount and the quantity and the quality
of those ideas and people is just
extraordinary
so that's what's really life-changing um
i think
i think at least for me i'm now an
entrepreneur uh
and uh and i'm so so happy i like
my life uh happiness has increased i
don't even know how much
i owe so much to that school yeah that's
incredible
that's incredible so talk to me a little
bit about what you're doing today with
280 group because i want to make sure we
have a good time for a really thoughtful
sure yeah
fair enough product management and how
you work there so i just said
at business school i realized i could be
an entrepreneur and i actually learned
something very interesting there which
was entrepreneurship through acquisition
so my husband is a founder i know what
it's like to be a founder it is so hard
and
michael i think you've interviewed a lot
of founders and you know they
have to be passionate about what they're
working on
because it is non-stop hard work
um i decided i am not sure
exactly what i'm passionate about yet
but there's a way for me
to become an entrepreneur and that's by
finding a business that's been around
for many years
which has already had product market fit
so it's de-risked
uh and i can learn so much from
the owner and founder and there's a lot
of businesses like this out there
um that you know especially in the small
small or nanocap private equity as i
would call it which is what doctor prime
was about
there's a lot of founders who don't
think about an exit strategy
and when they meet someone like me they
realize
uh that it could be a match right it
could be it could protect their legacy
uh they don't have to sell to private
equity and then worry about all their
people getting let go uh
they don't want to necessarily do a
merger with a competitor when
you know that's not their culture so
there's a lot of
benefits in uh you know people like
myself who realize i can be an
entrepreneur and i don't have to be a
founder
um there's a lot of challenges with that
as well but why 280 groups so it's
so it's really interesting i've been
reflecting on this a lot
so 280 group we do product management
training and consulting
we are the world's only company that i
know that does both and
those two elements are so so important
so in my summer
i worked at metlife in their office of
innovation where
i was trying to figure out how does
intrapreneurship
work at a large enterprise i was in the
office of innovation right they want to
innovate
um there's all these fintech companies
that are starting that they're
saying hey you know we need to we need a
way to
create um better products that suit
you know that are that focus on the end
consumer needs because if you think
about an insurance company they're
working with brokers so they're far
removed
and there's a lot of regulation right so
when i was there i realized in the
office of innovation in la tam
that's the region i was uh i was in uh
they did not understand what agile
methodology was i actually gave a
presentation on that
and it was so hard to be innovative it
was so hard to be innovative and that
is what uh i think if i'm reflecting
why i think 280 group is so powerful so
in a large company you have to
understand
the way those companies were built the
career ladder that was
not something that i was interested in
actually creates a command and control
culture
where decision making is built at the
top right
um and when you're thinking about the
way that companies innovate today
that decision making really needs to be
done on the front line
so product managers who are talking to
consumers and are also getting
information from customer support from
sales from all of these
other areas on the front line need to be
able to make clear decisions
about resources and allocating those
resources
in a large company that is really
challenging
if they are set up such that uh your
experience or your years of experience
signal you to be the right decision
maker
it doesn't work right it doesn't work um
innovation is really really hard and
that's why all of these companies
uh they struggle with how do we you know
we say digital transformation it's been
kind of like the word but
people don't understand it's mindsets
it's culture it's all of these things
that companies are not built upon
um so bringing me to 280 group we work
with these companies
uh and we hire people who love product
management they are so
so passionate they get up in the morning
because they want to have
true change or experience true impact
on an individual so we work with teams
but what gets us excited is when we see
not just the google reviews but
um oh gosh i'm gonna just say a story uh
i think roger was in seattle back when
we used to travel
and uh he was gonna do a training there
and he went to a coffee shop
and there was somebody who he had
trained like a year before
and who came up to him and said oh my
gosh i use the book
in the class and uh i i it's my
reference text now right so
this is these are the stories that
really drive us
um and bringing it back to organizations
that's what 280 group is so
so interesting for me so we know
that product management it's it's an
industry even though
it started it has its roots for over 100
years of brand management
um it's really evolved and it continues
to evolve over time
and the demands or the interests of
larger enterprise
recognize like recognizing hey product
management is important in our company
mean that um the demand for product
management is outpacing supply right
so we know this right um and
we know that this means that many people
who actually end up in product
management
don't come with a background of having
that experience
um they don't necessarily come into a
company with a very clear process
um they're not always onboarded uh
correctly
there's institutional knowledge that
maybe is not stored or related to them
there's all of these inefficiencies
right um and so
we know from from doing a
one of our benchmark reports that you
can all find it online i think we're
actually going to be redoing that one
this year
um we found that just training people
and by training i'm not even talking
about my training just letting people
know
what is product management and why you
know what do you do at each stage of the
product life cycle
helps increase skills by 11
um if you have a process that increases
skills by 30
and if you do both 44
so if i'm thinking well what kind of
company
do i want to run in this space that has
true impact it's one that combines both
of these
you can be trained we hear it all the
time we come in and train
we don't want to come in and train we
want to come in and change
right but how does that actually work
right now how does it tangibly work
because what i'm imagining is you have
this big corporation i mean part of the
challenge is you know
understanding the culture moving the
needle in a big corporation is much
harder and i'm guessing that
you know soon we'll talk about you know
the the comparison with startups but i
think one of the big differences
is really you know the pace and the
ability to just make quick decisions
and and move up and down the ladder
rather quickly you coming in
more of a consulting group and product
management group
how do you actually integrate into these
companies both quickly and efficiently
to quickly provide the value
but at the end also assimilate well
enough to be able to actually move the
needle and make that impact that you're
talking about
yeah um i'm going to just push back on
the word quick
there because it's not quick um no
matter
i i think uh you know if i'm going to
qualify the success of an opportunity or
an engagement before it begins
if there is looking for a quick solution
to something that
does not have a quick solution uh it's
not going to work i think
in in several cases where we do see true
impact um that's not just for a single
team now a single team can have a quick
win
right and we we've had experiences um
with uh with teams
where we train a team and they follow
our process
um and then they're able to launch on
time successfully
uh with all the customer requirements
happy customers uh
all of that so we have those case
studies and stories but if we're talking
about an organizational level which we
also work with
um it's it's it could be many years
right
um it could be it should definitely be
more than one year
and requires actually very
senior sponsorship this is not new for
us i think
you know the mckinseys and the deloittes
of the world know this too
that uh change takes time um the way
that we do it and the way that we
in terms of our process what makes it a
little bit more efficient is we do
we do not come into the organization
saying
we're going to now make you all follow
our optimal product process
we don't do that uh what we do instead
is say we're gonna spend the first
two three months uh of our engagement uh
talking to your people and that's not
just product management that's uh all
the people who touch product management
and it's not just the senior it's the
lower too right
so we're going to spend time getting to
know you we're going to take a look at
your documents
this is actually a really huge source of
information if you ask two different
teams or two different departments for
their documents and they don't look the
same
you have a problem right because that
means what does that mean
right that means when a product manager
moves from one department to another
um they don't know their expectations
right they don't know what they're
supposed to do
right um so it's all of these data
points that we start gathering and then
we produce a report uh
essentially a gap assessment where we we
provide uh
our you know what did we see
what can be improved um and a road map
um the way that we view our training
is we customize our training um to
include their terminology
to focus on um the elements that we've
identified
uh that need the most support um and
uh whenever possible uh
we uh we try to bring in people outside
of product management into the training
as well
to kind of level set what is product
management for the whole company
the biggest problem i think that we face
um at these kinds of organizations is
convincing the leadership
um to include or to budget
uh for a much larger uh
a much larger engagement uh which
which will have the most chance of
success right
so it's right yeah it's very involved
what i'm hearing you say arena is that
you're you know on one hand you can
think of
you know consultancy groups or or you
know other groups that are coming in and
saying okay we want to change
we want to improve this product we want
to solve this problem what you're saying
and
and i think that that's what i was
referring to the word quick which i now
understand was was
not the right way to refer to this
because what you're saying here you're
not looking to you know help a team or
help
person you're looking to make an
institutional change in the mindset of
how this organization is operating
and and and with that you know you're
you want to bring in people that are
outside of the product management domain
you want to bring in leadership
all the way to the lower levels to
really make sure that also it's part of
a cultural thing
and that you that you have to do and and
you know we have just a couple minutes
but i'd love to pick your brain on where
are we headed with this so yeah we know
that there's going to be a shortage of
product managers we already have that
today
where are we headed in terms of you know
the engagement with companies like 280
group or
or you know companies that have in-house
versus outsourcing
uh can you please rephrase that question
i'm not sure i understood that what
you're trying to find out
where are we headed with product
management as well
so i think so i think because what i'm
hearing you say right
right um so i think that there's a lot
of tools that are being developed right
now
uh that are i think more and more
important uh
that have to do with uh with reinventing
uh where product management or sits in
an organization
sorry i'm kind of being a little bit
verbose here but um
essentially product management is now
where where i see it going is um product
management is now
uh very much working in line with a lot
of
sources of data so um the tools that
product managers have
have increased and there's a lot more
demands from the product management
function at any organization so there
are things that are being developed
right now
product operations is a good one growth
product management
and growth product managers are another
one so there's a lot of things that are
changing and that has to do with the
changing
um changing demands of product
management uh
on top of companies trying to be a lot
more agile and a lot more digital
so these are very very high level words
but what they really mean is that
there's a lot more information about how
customers make decisions
uh and that information um there are a
lot of tools
now that allow product managers to uh
analyze that information
quicker um to be able to provide
much more rapid change that's basically
what i'm trying to say
does that come out i love it
first of all i think that you know one
of the amazing things that he said
earlier that i want to touch back on is
this idea that you know
in order to be an entrepreneur you don't
have to be a founder right you're an
entrepreneur
you know by any with any sense of the
word you don't have to
to be the founder of 280 group but but
you know the essence of being these
entrepreneurs to
identify gaps in the market identify
opportunities identify places right
the needle and i think that's exactly
what he did here i see
maybe i didn't understand your question
uh so there are skill cap
skill gaps um that are coming uh that
we're seeing more and more into the mark
in the market
and that has to do with the changing
role of the product manager and i think
that's kind of what i was trying to
explain
is product managers before didn't
necessarily have all these tools at
their disposal
and now i think the biggest challenge up
ahead is
uh to it's like that signal versus noise
issue with
with having all of this data the biggest
challenge one of the biggest challenge
product managers have is prioritization
and if they're being fed all of this new
data it's uh
it's it's really stems from the top in
terms of having a really clear-cut
product strategy um that allows them to
make prioritization decisions even with
larger amounts of data
so i hope that answers a little bit more
of that question
a hundred percent no no thank you and we
now thank you for being so generous with
your time and coming here i know how
busy you are
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
all right uh so i yeah three words that
i would describe myself
um the first one i would describe myself
as kind um
and that is not the same as nice i think
i am kind and that i
really i love like i said at the
beginning i love people and i love
seeing their potential
um and so i approach people with this
positive mindset and
i try to be kind um another one
i think my best friend probably
describes me as brave
um and i think that has to do with my
willingness to solve
hairy problems and challenges and take
on
take on things um like going out and
trying to find a business to buy
right which which makes me i guess maybe
a bit brave and courageous
um and then the third one is i'm
competitive i know that i am i play
volleyball i play pool i love challenges
i love problems and i love competing
um so those are my three parts i love
that
marina thank you so so much this is
wonderful and stay safe stay healthy
and very very excited she shared this
with the world thank you
thank you michael pleasure bye